Was existierte vor dem urknall stephen hawking hat dazu eine absolut bahnbrechende erklärung in der talkshow star talk von niederglatt heißen
Erklärte, er was vor dem urknall
existierte und seine erklärung ist verblüffend und
verstörend zugleich jetzt in klicks und science fiction herzlich willkommen
Wir wissen inzwischen immer genauer was seit dem urknall geschehen ist wie schnell
Passierte es wann entstanden die ersten sterne die galaxien und so weiter und so fort wir können schon sehr gut sagen
Und auch beweisen was da so alles
Passiert ist aber was war vor dem urknall stephen hawking hat jetzt in der wissenschafts talkshow star talk
Erklärt welche theorie er für das universum und die zeit davor hat und das ist wirklich ja ziemlich wie soll ich es sagen
seltsam oder unvorstellbar seine theorie sagt nichts
Wie soll das gehen da entsteht etwas aus dem nichts
Naja für ihn ist es etwas anders vor dem urknall gab es keine zeit und wenn es keine zeit gehabt gab es auch keinen davor
es ist also quasi unmöglich dass davor zu ergründen das kein
Davor gab es ist also nicht nur so dass davon nichts existiert es existierte auch kein davor es gab quasi
Keinen ort und keine zeit in der bzw dem etwas existieren hätte können das ist schon verrückt die
Kritische raumzeit des universums ist eine geschlossene oberfläche ohne ende sie ist eine einheit
Außer ihr gibt es demnach nichts man. Muss sie sich wie eine
Erdkugel vorstellen bei dem der urknall der südpol ist hinter dem südpol ist einfach nichts mehr
Ich finde das eine absolut verrückte vorstellung unser universum wäre demnach eine 4 dimensionale kugel ohne anfang ohne
Ende aber warum erleben wir dann alles so wie wir es erleben wir sehen nicht diese
Unendliche kugel auf der es keinen anfang und kein ende gibt wir sehen einen anfang und eine zukunft für uns ist die zeit
Eine in der einrichtung gerichtete dimension aber nach hawking ist es wahrscheinlich nicht
So diese sicht der dinge haben wir wahrscheinlich nur weil wir nicht anders existieren können wir würden vielleicht verrückt werden wenn wir diese
endlichkeit
verstehen würden teilchenphysiker spekulieren ja schon seit jahren darüber ob es
Interaktionen auf teilchen ebene mit der vergangenheit geben könnte mit der erklärung von hawking wäre das
verständlich er spricht auch von einer imaginären
Zeit die wahrscheinlich existiert und unsere zeit ist davon quasi nur eine falsche sicht vielleicht ein so wenig sowie
Wetter und klima das wetter können wir sehen spüren und können damit umgehen aber das große ganze ist für uns einfach nicht
verständlich die komplexen zusammenhänge
Wie die post die wellen in den jetstreams die sogar kälter werden lassen usw die sind verleihen auf jeden fall total unverständlich
Spannend wenn ihr kein video zum thema urknall und auch, zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann endet einfach meine nummer
Whatsapp hier gibt es einen link dafür da geht es direkt
zu meiner nummer dann bekommt ihr die videos vor allen andern von mir geschickt garantiert immer ihr könnt dort
direkt über mich in der redaktion von kriegs- und mitmachen und mit themen vorschlagen oder
an abstimmungen teilnehmen
Und dann direkt mitbestimmen was hier bei pixum passiert der direkte draht zu mir einfach hier draufklicken
und natürlich nicht das abo mit der
Genau glocke vergessen hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch. Draufklicken es gibt keine schwarzen löcher
Stephen hawking schmeißt alles um the hall wieder ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran